we've covered plenty of graphic settings
here with game tech but today we're
dealing with how much of a game we can
actually see so allow me to expand your
horizons with a quick look into how
field-of-view effects our games and its
relationship with aspect ratio and we'll
touch on the increasingly popular ultra
wide screen this is the part where I
advise you to subscribe to GameSpot so
do yourself a favor if you're not
subscribed already feel the view or fov
is the angle at which you see the world
through the in-game camera measured in
increments of single degrees the higher
the fov the more peripheral vision you
get but it will make the center look
farther away increasing the fov too much
will make it seem as if you're looking
through a fisheye lens here's an example
from doom it has an fov slider ranging
from 90 to 130 here's what the game
looks like with four different fov
settings pay attention to the demon head
and the pillars on the left and right as
fov goes up you'll see more of the
pillars in your peripheral vision but
the demon head at the center appears to
be farther we would suggest testing out
different movs to find the right balance
oftentimes a setting in the middle of
the allowed range works well I often
find games to have a default
fov a little too low for comfort but not
every game will let you change it
through the menu you need to find a way
to increase fov if you're not given a
menu option either via a third-party
application or by editing a game's ini
file some research needs to be done
since every game is going to have a
different process but in many cases it's
simply not possible however older games
such as my all-time favorite deus ex
which uses the original Unreal Engine
looks pretty damn sweet when you edit
the text file to do widescreen with a
proper fov here is it running in 1080p
with an fov of 105 it's an advantage to
have a high fov in competitive shooters
since it literally displays more of the
surrounding area look back at old
footage of competitive quake and you'll
see most players using a fisheye type of
fov many modern competitive games like
Battlefield 1 titanfall 2 and overwatch
also incorporate an MOV slider
now we can't have a proper discussion of
fov without mentioning aspect ratio
because it essentially dictates the
proper fov for a game back in the day
games were mostly played with a
resolution in a four by three aspect
ratio it feels much more cramped today
since widescreen has been the standard
for quite some time we commonly used
resolutions like 1080p 1440p and 4k
which are sixteen by nine occasionally
playing a game in widescreen will feel
too zoomed in which means the widescreen
setting is essentially a cropped version
of four by three when this happens we
don't get the extra real estate 16 by 9
or 16 by 10 offers cranking up the fov
solves this problem as it lets us see
more screen space and spreads it across
the wider resolution this leads into the
increasing popularity of ultra wide 21
by nine monitors which covers even more
real estate than standard widescreen but
for 21 by 9 to make sense you'd have to
crank up the fov even more we then get
into a gray area where we start to ask
how much is too much
fov for example you can set overwatch to
a 21 by 9 resolution but it'll be a
cropped version of 16 by 9 since you
can't really set an extreme fov
therefore it prevents you from really
getting a competitive advantage with the
extra screen space but battlefield One's
21 by 9 support is flawless and properly
covers your peripheral vision ultra wide
resolutions will be more demanding on
your hardware because it will have to
project more pixels using a higher fov
without increasing resolution may
slightly affect performance since your
PC will have to render more of the
game's assets what resolution aspect
ratio and fov do you like to use in
games feel free to share your thoughts
in the comments give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to our channel if you
haven't already and as always thanks for
watching